what is the true secret of the Ancients
and the ascended beings power welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and move it out
[Music]
okay it's fair to say the Ancients and
the ascended beings in Stargate are at
times a little contradictory
and understanding the power of the
ascended beings is a little difficult
because well they choose regularly not
to use them but I think I have figured
out what the actual true power and
strength of an ascended being is but I'm
going to come back to that a little bit
later first of all let's talk about the
Ancients and their powers because we
actually got to see them quite a bit now
we know obviously that the Ancients
evolved over millions of years and in
the period where many atlanteans in
ancients began to ascend we saw the
ancient race become the Pinnacle of that
Evolution while they still had a
Corporal form but what powers did they
have we saw ancient beings have very
powerful telekinesis abilities we saw
them have some limited telepathy we saw
very powerful sensory abilities and like
the big man Jesus himself they could
heal by touch now we know there is the
ancient repository of information and we
know that the Asgard had access to that
Thor told O'Neill we have accessed this
information and even the Asgard have
barely been able to scratch the surface
now we know how intelligent and how
powerful and how technologically
advanced the Asgard were so just imagine
how advanced and Powerful the Ancients
were
now we actually got to see that a little
bit once or twice for example fights in
the replicators it wasn't the Asgard or
some new technology that was used to
defeat the replicators it was ancient
technology millions of years old if you
haven't subscribed already please do and
like and share the video wherever the
hell you want also if you enjoy the
content and you want to support the
Channel please hit the join button also
we have our sister Channel Sidetrack
size where we do lots of little best
bits from the lives and lots of other
fun silly little videos so please go and
subscribe to sites
we also got to see a little bit more
when Merlin decided to descend and fight
back against the aura he was able to
control technology with his mind he was
able to know where a Stargate was and to
activate it with just a thought now that
tends to suggest that maybe he could
actually control more than just the
Stargate and maybe he could control lots
of ancient technology
but eventually all of these ancient
beings did either die or Ascend now
obviously the ascended are beings of
energy they've shed their Corporal form
all of this meat and they've just become
an energy or being of light they
ascended to a higher plane now I do
wonder what these higher planes are but
in physics today we believe that there
are actually more than just the three
dimensions that we live in or four if
you include time that actually there may
be 11 12 millions of Dimensions or
folded in and existing within the same
space it seems to me that that's what
hyperspace is and it seems to me as well
that that's probably where the ascended
beings are and a different dimension
within our own space a dimension where
only energy exists and there's no matter
now this is where we get into the
problem of trying to understand how the
ascended beings Powers work or even what
Powers they have because they chose to
barely ever use them now we got to see
the all right and again we didn't really
see their power either but that was more
because they couldn't be bothered and
want to and that's because of the
ascended beings in our galaxy we're
actually protecting us from them so they
couldn't just snap us out of existence
Thanos style they had to send an army
you're right
gain their power from the lower planes
so much so that one day they shall be
strong enough to wipe the others out
in the face of such a threat the strict
policy of non-interference is absurd
but we did get to see the Ancients in
our galaxy use their powers once or
twice in Stargate Atlantis episode
Sanctuary we got to see chayasar now she
was able to destroy an entire wraith
Fleet with just her mind she protected
the planet proculus and then was
punished by the rest of the Ancients she
was forced to only be able to protect
proculus again in the future
to me it was almost like she was
imprisoned on the planet she saved but
this to me is the biggest clue to
understand the ascended beings power but
we'll come back to that in just one
minute because it has been suggested
more than once that the ascended beings
have almost unlimited knowledge
now that is a big claim and that is
really getting into god-like stuff here
but vaccines have almost unlimited
knowledge before they ascended so then
give them the ability to travel amongst
the stars without aging Without Really
any limits on where or what they can do
it makes sense that they would just
become all-powerful but Stargate
Universe suggested that there was more
they suggested that there were beings
out there that had even more power than
the Ancients they suggested that there
was this being or some sort of
intelligence that actually encoded a
message into the background radiation of
the universe a message that would have
been sent before time perhaps that once
you ascend you can tap into that
knowledge a knowledge of the entire
universe and that makes you God's
but the ascended beings are a little bit
contradictory at times
now I mentioned that as an ascended
being you can travel amongst the stars
with almost no limit but at times we
actually see ascended beings use the
Stargate now having to use a Stargate
and having to pass through walls and
things like we saw ascended beings do
once or twice does descend to suggest a
limit to that power
but then we saw other ascended beings
just appear Daniel traveled amongst the
stars and just appeared where he needed
to instantly now this sense is just as a
being of energy that they can pass to
their higher plane and then back into
our reality in any location they like
but again we have seen the contradiction
of using the gate so get in the comments
and explain that one to me if you can
but let's be honest there are lots of
contradictions when it comes to the
Ancients and the ascended beings and
there are lots of contradictions when it
comes to the gold why were some of their
architecture this ancient stone
monuments for example the super weapon
at dakara or the ancient knowledge
repository but then other architecture
was like Atlantis futuristic and Metal
again these sorts of contradictions
don't really make sense but they looked
really cool on screen so this gets me
into what I really think the power of an
ascended being is
now as I mentioned cheyasa was able to
destroy an entire wraith Fleet it just
blinked out of existence
I think this is because the ascended
beings have the power over matter and
energy they can change matter into
energy and energy into matter this would
make sense because they've changed their
bodies into a being of energy when they
ascended now that ability would give
them almost unlimited power
nobody can stand against an ascended
being because you can just blink them
out of existence
now we know that the ascended beings
choose not to interfere in our galaxy
now there are lots of contradictions
when it comes to that as well now for
example when omadasala accidentally half
ascended Anubis and she was punished
non-interference pact suggests that they
allowed Anubis because of free will
because their most important law is that
everyone should have free will
but Anubis had knowledge of the ascended
and he had knowledge of the Ancients so
the damage was done but the ascended
being still didn't step in there are
many planes of existence
between human existence and Ascension
basically
the others used their Collective powers
to keep him from affecting anything on a
grand Cosmic level but it's okay for him
to destroy an entire galaxy it's okay
for him to do anything he could have
done back when he was a regular old Goa
old
now the contradiction there again is
that they say Free Will is the most
important rule but they don't seem to
step in when one person's Free Will
seems to overpower or eliminate
another's or perhaps what's more
important to them is that they know that
absolute power corrupts absolutely they
knew that they could not get involved in
our Affairs because if they started they
might never stop and they'd seen in the
Ori what the result of that would be so
guys get into the comments tell me what
you think is there anything I'm
forgetting about the Ancients or the
ascended beings that gives us a little
bit more insight into what they were how
they worked and what powers they had I'd
love to read your comments and let's
start the discussion if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification really helps us
out and as always if you enjoy the
content and you want to become a fully
fledged side Trekker consider hitting
the join button as always please stay
safe I'll see you next time
[Music]